you can
find water but you can't even find your
own children
imacs just seems like such a fantastic
medium for this type of movie
if it's going to have an emotional play
you know on a smaller screen then
it's only going to be exponentially
bigger on this sort of screen
and when you have a film like this that
has battle sequences and storm sequences
and
you know steam train sequences then
you're in a a place where the platform
for that emotional response is just
bigger it's a big film like an old
school sort of epic
sweeping love story the backdrop is the
fall of the ottoman empire so
it's perfect for imax you kind of need
as big a canvas to play it on as you
possibly can
that's certainly the way russell
envisaged it is that it should be
the big canvas but the personal story
it's just a big beautiful emotional
piece and there's lots of action in it
it's just huge
let's get back into that emotional
explosion which you know
so many of us that's the reason we
connect the feature films in the first
place
every film is important to see a
nightmare i measure a man by how much he
loves his children
not by what the world has done to them
come on you can take people
on the journey like old school journey
he's alive i know he is the size of the
screen
is sort of uh the way it used to feel
when you went to movies
back when i was a kid
you